with a lot of concern about the cost of
US healthcare which makes good sense and
it's going to tank the economy there's
about twice as much per capita as
comparable countries as some of the
worst outcomes and it's growing pretty
fast so yeah that's a real problem and a
lot of criticism of Obama's plan from
the right as it's called is going is
that's too expensive well there's some
pretty easy ways to cut down the expense
for example the United States the only
industrial country that by law does not
permit the government to use its
purchasing power to negotiate drug
prices the one effect is the drug prices
are way higher than anywhere else well
what does the public think about this
the few polls there are show that
approximately eighty-five percent of the
public thinks we ought to do it it's not
even on the agenda in fact a week or so
ago the New York Times had a front-page
article saying that Obama had made a
secret deal with the drug companies in
which he assured them that there would
be no such